Berliner Sportakrobaten zeigen ihr Können.
Mittendrin auch der 16-jährige Arman
Boyraz und seine jüngere Schwester Bilge:
die einzigen Deutschtürken
in diesem Turnverein.
Die stolzen Eltern legen Wert auf
gute Integration ihrer Kinder.
Ein überwiegend von Türken
besuchter Fußballverein etwa
wäre für sie nicht in Frage gekommen.
Hinterher spendiert Familie Boyraz
türkische Wassermelonen.
Ihr Motto: dazugehören und dennoch
seine türkischen Wurzeln nicht vergessen.
Und mit der Zeit fühlen wir uns
hier sehr wohl eigentlich in Berlin,
eigentlich wie zu Hause – aber drüben auch.
Also bei mir ist leider … in beiden
Ländern bin ich so fest verankert,
zurzeit, aber ich fühl mich in
beiden Ländern eigentlich sehr wohl.
Arman ist hier geboren und
hat deshalb das Recht
auf die deutsche und die
türkische Staatsbürgerschaft.
Ihn wurmt, dass das nun wieder
zur Diskussion steht.
Für ihn heißt das: entweder – oder.
Deutsch oder türkisch?
Durch diese beiden Pässe verbinden
sich so gesagt [sozusagen] die Länder,
und dann baut man auch Brücken auf
zwischen verschiedenen Kulturen.
Und dadurch – wie soll ich sagen
– wird Deutschland,
obwohl es auch sehr multikulturell wird,
vielleicht noch multikultureller.
Doch im deutschen Wahlkampf
wirbt die CDU wieder
für die sogenannte Optionspflicht.
Danach müsste sich Arman
spätestens mit 24 Jahren
für einen der beiden Pässe entscheiden:
eine politische Kehrtwende und
Reaktion auf die Politik
des türkischen Staatspräsidenten Erdogan.
Denn der macht hier für sich Wahlkampf
bei den rund 1,4 Millionen Deutschtürken
und gibt Wahlempfehlungen für
die deutsche Bundestagswahl.
Und das ist eben mit ein Grund dafür,
warum viele, viele in der CDU sagen,
es kann so eine Einmischung
in unsere Kultur,
in unsere Lebensweise,
nicht von außen geben.
Zu seiner Enttäuschung findet
Arman auch nebenan
bei der liberalen Oppositionspartei FDP
keine überzeugten Freunde der
doppelten Staatsbürgerschaft.
Ich wollte wissen, was Ihre
Partei dazu sagt?
Das ist ja nichts, was man mal gibt und
dann nach Belieben wieder wegnimmt.
Aber irgendwann, wenn die Leute
halt ewig hier leben,
muss irgendwann halt mal eine
endgültige Entscheidung her.
Finden Sie es richtig, dass dieses Recht
nur von der Türkei entzogen wird,
aber anderen europäischen Ländern nicht?
Nein, das müsste dann überall so sein.
Aber Sie wissen ja selber, dass
es mit der Türkei jetzt wirklich
sehr schwierig geworden ist.
Und da können wir ja auch nichts dafür.
Nur türkisch, nur deutsch oder beides –
in der Familie Boyraz ist alles vertreten.
Doch einfach ist das nicht.
Während die Kinder mit beiden
Staatsangehörigkeiten aufwachsen,
tun sich die Eltern mit
einer Entscheidung schwer.
Wenn wir jetzt dann unsere – sagen wir
– türkische Staatsbürgerschaft
dann auch abgeben würden,
würden wir auch dort dann diskriminiert.
Das heißt dann, was wollt
ihr dann Deutschtürken.
Ihr habt nicht mal die
türkische Staatsbürgerschaft!
Was sucht ihr dann? So nach dem Motto.
Arman will in seiner
Heimatstadt Berlin bleiben.
Aber der türkische Pass ist für ihn so etwas
wie die Brücke in die Heimat seiner Eltern.
Ich hoffe, dass es nicht so weit kommt
und ich zu solch einer [vor solch eine]
Wahl gestellt werden muss.
Und deswegen … natürlich würde ich
also zum deutschen tendieren,
aber das würde schon im Herzen wehtun.
Was Arman ärgert, ist, dass auch
gut integrierte türkische Jugendliche
wie er durch den Streit zwischen
Berlin und Ankara
einen Teil ihrer Identität
verlieren könnten.